we've had a we've had a record-breaking
year in 2021 you know we
2021 saw startups in africa raise 4.3
billion dollars you know more than
2018 19 and 20 combined so it's a very
exciting time right now in the in the
tech space and in the vc space in africa
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
in africa talking to odessa rhodes
founding partner and ceo arua capital
management one of the few women owned
and led private equity funds in africa
she's leading investment professional
and ceo with over 13 years of experience
in investment banking and private equity
and developed in emerging markets across
a number of sectors including healthcare
financial services technology and
consumer goods
and this is an entrepreneur ceo mother
investor and women's empowerment
advocate she's one of the youngest
female private equity fund managers
running her own fund in africa having
launched her fund at 29 years old
adesua akundo rhodes thank you so much
for joining me all the way from nigeria
to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm very well thank you it's great to be
here thank you for having me it is it is
an honor to have you here adesua you're
you're leading such an incredible
journey and you're you're solving some
incredible problems and you're you're
working on some fascinating
topics in your day-to-day and i'm so
honored to have you here to share with
me your journey and your perspective and
insights and work in these 20 minutes um
in in really short one of the most
interesting things i have to say is the
fact that you worked in lehman brothers
until august of 2008
i don't know if you if you were a
prophet and saw what was going to happen
a few months later but that's
fascinating
you know different jobs in investment
banking and amazing positions in places
like jp morgan and syntax's capital as a
partner and then he is holding several
board of director positions but now most
notably the founding partner and ceo of
aurora capital management and they're
really making a really big impact on
africa and the african ecosystem and as
a whole adesua
how do you define yourself how do you
define your career
yeah so i would say that um
my career has been one of um i would say
persistence
there's been a lot of um
i would say challenges being a young
african black woman
uh trying to raise capital in a private
equity ecosystem that's dominated by
white men no offense um
but uh but yeah i would say my like my
career has really been one of
persistence one of
growth uh one of different seasons uh
and i'm very very happy to be where i am
now where i'm you know you know being
able to fulfill you know the dream and
my dream of being able to use my
platform to help close gender find you
know gender funding gaps on the
continent so
so yeah it's been you know 13 years of
experience
uh in investment banking and private
equity as you mentioned some of those
names lehman brothers jp morgan
but really got excited to spin out of my
previous fund and and start my own
private equity fund
where we're intentionally investing in
businesses that are either founded and
led by women or businesses that are
providing essential goods and services
to women because we see that as such as
an untapped
uh of opportunity you know as a woman
allocating capital i'm best placed i
believe to invest in the best businesses
that are producing solutions to problems
that i understand as a woman and as an
end user
uh it's a 15 trillion dollar female
economy women are making 80 of consumer
spending decisions wow so you know
there's so much limited competition in
that space because historically men are
the ones allocating capital you know i
read a statistic that said that
white men are controlling 98.7 percent
of the 69 trillion dollars under
management so
uh it we live in a world where only 1.3
percent is being managed by women and
minorities which is obviously a huge
problem but i see that as a huge
arbitrage opportunity right so
we can invest in their blind spots and
and have a very competitive advantage to
enhance returns for our investors so
yeah very excited about what we're doing
with the rural capital and you know
happy to talk more on on on the gaps
that we see in the market well we'll
take me back to the founding of a rural
capital
you know two years and seven months ago
or three years ago you're standing there
and
what what what is this sort of the
vision that you have or what what is the
what is the catalyst that is bringing
you to do this
yeah sure it's really because you know i
struggle to fundraise you know i
struggle to fundraise
um from institutional investors so
i always say if you can't see it and you
can't be it
so i couldn't see people like me
um you know uh getting capital and
allocating capital so i said well if i
can't see people like me it's going to
be very very hard for these institutions
to invest in me
so with the rural capital it was really
born out of a frustration at the system
but also a
big onus to be the change that i want to
see
by using aurora as a case study and to
really showcase that this is what can
happen
when
women are empowered as capital
allocators you know there is a triple
bottom line effect because there is an
we have a natural competitive advantage
to enhance returns because as you invest
in women we're two times more likely to
invest in female founders
where we're more likely to improve
gender diversity in our in our in our
portfolio companies and now there's so
much research out there that shows that
gender diversity helps to improve
performance helps to enhance returns
helps to reduce risk
so we're really really excited to just
showcase that through that natural
trickle down effect of having women as
capital allocators
uh there is an enhancement of return but
also if you care about social impact
women invest in everyone else women are
reinvesting 90 of their income into
healthcare or education so
there is so much poverty there's so much
uh uh poverty alleviation that can be
had through this strategy because we're
investing in basic health care and
education for our families there is
multiplier effect in terms of job
creation
so there's a real triple bottom line
effect with our strategy in terms of
enhanced return social impact and gender
equality so we're very very excited
about that so yeah that's my vision is i
want other women to be able to point to
arua see the successes that we've had
and not go through the same six-year
fundraising journey and challenges that
i've had to go through
because they would have you know someone
else that's making the business case for
women
if you're taking me 30 000 feet in the
air into the landscape of nigeria ghana
maybe africa in general
what are we observing today
on on a general
you know tech investment side but then
more specifically about the gender gap
yeah you know we've had a we've had a
record-breaking year in 2021 you know we
2021 saw startups in africa raise 4.3
billion dollars you know more than
2018 19 and 20 combined
so it's a very exciting time right now
in the in the tech space and in the vc
space in africa but when you drill
deeper into those numbers the reason
funds like aurora exist
is exactly this less than one percent of
that capital that was raised is going to
female founders
um single male founders have raised over
100 times
more than female founders on the
continent and the reason that we have
those disparities is we don't have
enough women allocating capital if we
have more women allocating capital if we
have more women in the investment
decision making roles then we'll be able
to be we'll be able to see
you know female founders have a larger
portion of that pie um so you know from
a fact you know 30 000 feet up the
numbers look great the tech sector is
burgeoning but we're not seeing women
women well represented in those numbers
we're also not seeing a lot of local
investors being represented in those
numbers we're seeing a lot of foreign
investors coming in to you know take up
these rounds
so you know we're having a few
challenges i would say in the ecosystem
uh but you know we're excited that you
know we're finally able to showcase the
untapped potential that africa
represents and i think the whole world
is waking up to that now
and so
as you're
participating actively as an as an
investor and as a board member
how are you
shifting the mentality
both of the
founders that you're working with as
well as those that that you're meeting
on a regular basis for investment
opportunities what sort of persona are
you bringing into this
as a part of
trying to help bridge the gap of the the
gender gap here
yeah so it's really one that you know we
have to make sure that it's commercial
uh we make it very very clear that we're
not doing this for charity this is not
to tick a box this is not a feel-good
thing
uh you know i'm a capitalist and an
investment banker at heart
uh and you know we make sure that it's a
commercial discussion you know we think
gender diversity will improve the
profitability of your business it's
going to it's going to improve your
bottom line so we make it very very
clear that you know as we think about
gender diversity on the ball at the
board level as we think about it in your
workforce as we think about it in your
supply chain as we think about it in
your senior management team
we're doing this because we strongly
believe that will bring value it's not
something that we're doing for charity
um and you know the numbers prove it and
everywhere else in the world and it's
really just making sure that we can
showcase that for africa as well
um you know uh bcg uh have have have
research on this you know they they said
for every dollar that's invested in a
startup
female founded startups are generating
2.5x more than male founders
yes uh so there's so much statistics on
this in other parts of the world we just
need to be able to showcase what's also
possible in africa where africa is a
region that has the highest rate of
female entrepreneurship in the world
actually
yes one in four women are managing or
starting businesses on the continent
four times
four times more than in europe
so when you have that level of female
entrepreneurship and then i tell you
that less than one percent of the 4.3
billion being raised has gone to female
founders you can see that there is a
dislocation there
but we see it as a huge arbitrage
opportunity because you know we're one
of the very few
uh earn funds uh locally on the ground
that are investing in this space
unbelievable how do you explain the fact
that one in four women in africa are
business owners or starting their
businesses and that
on
on average a female entrepreneur returns
2.5x male entrepreneur
yeah you know
these these disparities are there and i
think that they're there because
there is unconscious bias in the system
you know where we don't have women in
those invest in investment decision
making rooms you know you have a woman
asking for capital in front of five men
um you know
there's just not that uh there's just
not that gender balance in the
investment decision making so
so i think there's unconscious bias in
the system and that can only be um you
know alleviated as we have more through
our capitals and we have more women
actually writing the checks
going back to you a little bit and your
own journey here
how do you see your journey moving
forward what is sort of your vision is
it more in the on the on the investment
side on on on the changing the landscape
side are they maybe just the same
mission intertwined in one how how do
you see your own journey unfold moving
forward
yeah i think i think you know that is
really the mission is we want to we want
to we want to have a dent in the
financial ecosystem in africa
and be able to
you know use our platform to change the
system and be able to use our platform
to be able to encourage institutional
investors to invest in women as capital
allocators um change the cons you know
the the the assumptions that you know if
you're investing in women it's pink and
soft and it's you know it's not
commercial uh you know we want to be
able to we have tangible stories that
otherwise wouldn't have been told
without our capital where we can
showcase that you can make money you can
have social impact you can have tangible
women economic empowerment outcomes you
can you know you can alleviate poverty
you can create jobs you can achieve
gender equality you know uh all at the
same time and that's really what we want
to be able to showcase and i think as we
do that
we will have an impact in the financial
ecosystem where
investing in a woman as a fund manager
investing in a women as entrepreneur
will no longer be an exception to the
role but will be the norm that's really
the vision that i have
i love it
can you remember when this all started
for you specifically looking at the
gender gap was there an aha moment that
sort of led you there was it during
investment banking or later what made
you so passionate about this
it was really just from lived experience
and i think that's where
yeah yeah when you have lived experience
you know i was one of those female
entrepreneurs
um so so when you have lived experience
um you know it comes from the stomach as
we say
so you know i've been one of those
female entrepreneurs you know trying to
raise capital i i know how how tough it
is how difficult it is
um so if i can play my own part in
making it easier for other women to
raise capital
um then i think that i would have
fulfilled you know some part of my
purpose here on earth
so obviously the tradition that the
trajectory that you're taking is is
female first and you're and you're
really being intentional and deliberate
about closing the gender gap from from
aurora's perspective if we're looking at
the greater landscape of investors and
i'm in venture capital as well and
there's you know thousands of vcs around
the world
what is something that
vcs can do actively
that would really move the needle here
is it simply just saying hey everybody
focus more on on female on female
founded entrepreneurs female founded
starbs because they're there and they
actually are often doing better is that
just the solution or is there more
education that needs to go into this
market
yeah i think i think there is i think
it's i think there is some education
that needs to be had uh i think it's you
know not just investing in a female
funded startup based on you know wanting
to check a tick box you know they have
to
because if we do that then we do more
harm to the to the system than if we you
know right so it's making sure that
you're investing in sustainable
businesses but being intentional you
know when you're screening a lot of the
unconscious bias happens in the
screening phase
um so when you're screening just be
intentional to just you know listen to
the pitch
um you know don't just you know don't
just you know wash it off because it's
two female founders coming to pinchy
something uh essentially touching here
is that there's this dramatic
inconsistency when you're saying that
that often females have a harder time
getting getting funded yet they're
showing greater returns this means that
investors are doing a bad job it's plain
and simple
well yeah yeah
they're they're they're they're and and
i think that the you know you say it as
investors doing a bad job i just think
that there is an imbalance in the
capital allocators uh if because we
don't have
we if we don't have gender balance in
the people allocating capital you're not
going to have gender balance in the
outcomes correct um so so i think that's
where the issue is but you know a lot
can be done um
and a lot can be done in terms of just
being intentional when you're screening
um having more women on your investment
decision you know in the investment
committee and your investment
professionals and men also just being
more kind of open to
um to different you know founders to
different markets that maybe they don't
understand
uh you know there there's a lot that can
be done but yes it's not it's i would i
would stay away from just saying invest
in every female startup that you see
female founded startup that you see
because that would do more harm than
good if some of them are not being
invested on based on you know
fundamental analysis of you know is this
a good investment is this a good
investment because i think for us we're
very very conscious that for this to be
sustainable for this to be scalable we
need to make money um so so i think that
that's something that we're very very
conscious about as well
how do you work with your entrepreneurs
once you invest in them what kind of
work do you do with them
you know on on a regular basis as a part
of your role
yeah sure so we're very hands-on so
we're a local investor we're based in
lagos we're investing in nigeria so
we're hands-on
we make sure that as we invest we're
improving corporate governance you know
sitting on the boards we make sure that
we're improving operational systems and
processes you know you know in the
finance function in accounting and
reporting
we really are very intentional about
institutionalizing the businesses that
we invest in because as we do that they
become very very attractive
for other private equity funds to invest
but also it helps us monitor our risks
effectively as well by making sure that
we have a finger on the pulse on the
operations of the business
um so yeah we're we're
we're active hands-on uh investors
because we're local we can be
you mentioned that you know your your
idea for arua started out as a catalyst
of out of
your own experience fundraising what
what is the biggest
pain point or struggle that you see
female
leaders and female entrepreneurs having
now as ceos or as co-founders and
companies once they're there once
they've made the investment and they're
on to the next stage of the company what
what are some of the biggest challenges
that they then face that you're helping
them also overcome
um interesting i would say that
maybe um
i think there is a gap uh in in
this the next stage of capital that
needs to be raised
um
so
i would say that you know they get their
they get their um
we've invested in them we've
institutionalized them and then it's now
looking for that next round of capital
uh because again we don't have the
gender balance at every stage of the
ecosystem in terms of the funds that are
allocating um you know it's it's okay
for aurora to be in this space but then
we don't have another
the next phase
right um so so i would say it's that
there's a there's a scale-up there might
be a scale-up issue
um later in making sure that we have
the gender balance of capital allocators
across each stage of the investing
ecosystem
i love it
and that's why are you optimistic
i'm very optimistic i'm very hopeful uh
you know africa is getting it's it's
it's it's moment in the sun right now uh
there's you know everyone is excited
about our vcc our vc scene our tech
scene so i'm very very hopeful that you
know as
more investors start to see more
unicorns emerge from the african
continent
um you know we will we will have more
funds we'll have more rulers
uh we will have you know the gender
balance that we seek in these startups
i'm very very hopeful uh
there i think there is we're moving in
the right direction for sure and that's
why thank you so much for these 20
minutes but more importantly thank you
for all the great work that you're doing
uh to to your country to the continent
to the world and really i'd say i think
it's that's really moving the needle and
i and i learned a lot in these 20
minutes so thank you very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you very much michael thanks for
reaching out it's been a pleasure have a
good rest of the week thank you
[Music]